I went to an all-black Church and I was
the the lightest person and I was the
lightest person in the entire
congregation like the yeah I stood out
like a sore thumb but it's just because
my dad is my dad is like white and
native and so in my mom's black so I
just I just looked different so I was
very easy to say for them to say oh
you're not like us you know church yeah
that's very odd okay very christ-like
yeah I mean it got arm it got very bad
and they were they started first they
started bullying and then they started
hitting me they hit you like well punch
you in the face you know what mad cuz
you had a nice straight hair that's why
we got to pay for this [ __ ] it was it
was it was really bad like it's like
it's such a it was such like a
traumatizing event for me I'm gonna tell
you this story I feel like I shouldn't
even I feel like I just go ahead damn
what if us are crying David Thank You
cries yeah everybody cries on this and I
look Oprah's table every day books like
this wait until he strikes me okay so
it's gonna seem really silly but like
basically I was going through months of
mental and physical abuse by like the
same like group of girls yeah like just
the same group of girls and for
literally no reason other than probably
that I was light-skinned and my mom's an
author so like I was well I'm like
fairly like well-spoken you know and I
was just different and and so like one
day I was forced to go to this sleepover
at the church it was like a lock-in and
I didn't want to go because I didn't
have any friends and I kept telling my
parents like my mom my grandma like I
don't want to go I don't want to go
don't make me go please don't make me go
they made me go anyways and um it was
nobody talked to me the whole night I
was basically by myself and at one point
I saw some boys playing video games and
I've been playing video games cuz I was
a really lonely kid so I walked over and
I went to play video games with them and
I guess some of the girls had a crush on
some of the boys and they didn't like
that I went over and talked to them in
their eyes they're like oh look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm like 10 you know
I'm not even ten I'm like seven you know
but it's just you guys are playing video
games I play that game at home I want to
play with you so I start playing with
the boys and I'm pretty good at this
game
you look exactly
[ __ ] slide this gets [ __ ] weird
right and this I'm also telling you why
I'm not religious yeah so uh so we so we
go like everyone like I played video
games with them I don't remember that
much I was really young and then we all
go to bed
we have this like sleeping like sleeping
things or whatever yep um and then like
I wake up at like early in the morning
and it's dark everybody's asleep and I
have this stuff like all over me and I
touch it and I thought that it was blood
and like I'm like seven you know and I I
really thought that it was blood and so
I scream I just like scream because I
feel this stuff I don't know what it is
I'm like scared and anxious they flipped
on the lights and these [ __ ] had just
put ketchup and mustard all over me they
covered my entire body with ketchup and
mustard
yeah like while I was sleeping they had
like like everywhere and so like I I'm
embarrassed because I had just woken up
everyone in the room it was a huge room
I'm embarrassed this woman had to like
clean me up and like I'm like I'm like
why did they do this why did they do
this but then like I just get like angry
after that like I went [ __ ] cold like
I shut down as a kid like I have been
dealing with like physical abuse like I
was getting beat up I was getting
[ __ ] like yell that I was getting
spit on by these girls I didn't know and
then this was just like it like this was
last straw so this is like where it gets
weirder this is where it gets even
weirder David I can't believe I'm
telling this story there's my shot this
is very personal to me yeah so so um
this was this is a really traumatizing
event for me as a kid because and and I
I'm also okay with telling this because
as miniscule as it seems I think it's
important to remind yourself of trauma
and things that are a shock to your
system you know because this really was
because I felt betrayed by you know my
grandparents and my mom that I'd made me
go when I begged not to go I did not
want to go back to this place I was fed
up at this point I was embarrassed I was
hurt like everything and like I went
cold as like a seven or eight-year-old
child like I was [ __ ] done yeah
but um so that happened on like a Friday
or Saturday night and my mom had to come
pick me up and like I could tell that
she was like really destroyed because um
she she wanted she wanted to make her
mom happy and my grandma my grandma was
very religious so my mom felt like she
had I had to go to this church I had to
be a Christian and my mom felt hurt
because she was like I can't believe I
[ __ ] let my child go like after you
know I had been seeing her come home
like upset from children's church every
day and and so it was just kind of it
was like [ __ ] and so my mom like calls
like the pastor and is like what you
guys watch Jesus Christ what's up [ __ ]
excuse me sorry in the name of Jesus
Christ are you [ __ ] kidding yeah and
so like this is like a big deal and like
people in the church are talking about
it and [ __ ] - they're like oh oh that's
uh that's that's brother Percy's kid
yeah just you know there's like murmurs
and [ __ ] like that and then with my
prayers so we go to church on Sunday
this is where it gets [ __ ] weird
so we go to church on Sunday and it's a
black church you know any black folks
out there y'all ever been to a black
church you know this is just like two
hours so at the end of the sermon
entirely in front of the entire
congregation which is like 200 people
the pastor calls up the three girls that
did this to me and asked them to come to
the front of the church calls em by name
and tells them to come up and he takes
this [ __ ] water and he goes I curse
you and your families I'm not [ __ ]
kidding David he's like your eyes just
went like what the [ __ ] - these like the
girl I don't know pastors had that power
curse you I curse you and your families
this sounds like it's out of a [ __ ]
movie I swear on god this happened I
don't know if this guy thought that
doing this would make you feel better
yeah or my family feel better but
instead it was shaming the three girls
and all of their families who were in
the congregation and keep in mind it's
not just mom and dad going it's mom dad
brother sister on uncle so three girls
let's just multiply that by five 15
people in the congregation they've got
friends of friends to me as a child I
felt like every
that congregation [ __ ] hated me for
being such a little [ __ ] you know like
and that was it that was the end of the
sermon he did that and he dismissed
everybody you know and I still had to go
to that church for a few years
damn what was that like after damn dude
that [ __ ] me up like it was I and you
know what the [ __ ] up thing is I don't
remember I was done I was completely
done with the world after that you know
and I mean like in that that wasn't the
only like unfortunate thing happened in
my life you know the like there's
there's like a few just like small
things that basically the world told me
very early on before I was even 10 years
old that nobody wants you here yeah like
that's what I was told
and that's and I saw the world through a
lens of that you know yeah and it was
yeah it was really rough and like to be
fair man I really can't tell you because
I don't I don't remember I just blocked
it out you know and it took me it took
me a long time to clean my Sundays back
yeah which I'm like super happy to say I
have them back now for years I dreaded I
hated Christmas and I hated Sundays you
hated Christmas that's just a white dude
with a beard I was done I was I was
because it meant it just meant it just
meant going back and so like I would
like as a kid I would like you know
Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday psych was
like cool and then Saturday would hit
and I knew Sunday was going becoming and
I had to go back to the church so for
like years and years and years I was
shut off to that you know and and you
know another thing is and like my mom's
probably gonna listen the [ __ ] we've
talked about it like I don't really care
another thing is that like it's it's
kind of that thing we talked about again
with the bubble my mom never she never
went through a depressed phase like
adding yourself phase so she didn't know
how deep my pain went with this stuff
could empathize she she didn't
understand you know and like it was like
a big deal for us like later on in life
to like come back and be like you know
like I forgive you and I didn't
understand you know it was really big
but I got my Sundays back I respect
Christianity now I can't have y'all
crazies running around but yes you know
you know a lot of people do have like
these very traumatizing experiences but
like
at church and it's and it's kind of sad
because even for me to like I've had
those experiences yeah and like I had to
figure out for myself it's like well man
dude I remember uh there was it's maybe
it's because I think everything's funny
maybe lying go cry this is hilarious
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy man so I
used to flip between two different
churches well three different churches
because my friends went there so every
now and then I would ask my mom you can
I spend the night on Saturday at their
house so I can go to church with them my
mom's like oh cool but there was one
church that I really liked going to
because I thought it was such a [ __ ]
up church because this dude so these two
brothers known to be hyper temperamental
you're talking about the stereotypical
Korean angry dudes these two dudes were
[ __ ]